the movie opens up with a guy named Dave
Lockwood who is married and has three
children including Twins and an older
daughter he is awakened by the cries of
his twins from another room Dave heads
in like it's the seventh circle of hell
and proceeds to change their diapers
during this process the babies create a
mess one squirts milk powder onto Dave's
face and the other excretes directly
onto him an image I will never be able
to forget despite this he manages to
change the diapers and brings them to
the living room while feeding them milk
the next morning Dave heads to work
where he's approached by a law associate
named Sabrina she hands him some files
and during their interaction he notices
a tattoo on her forearm furthermore he
stares at her admiringly as she walks
away and his secretary catches him
red-handed later Dave receives a call
from his best friend Mitch Planko who is
still single and lives in a messed up
apartment Mitch has been doing bong rips
and playing with swords a Pitch Perfect
2000's image of a a single 30-year-old
they haven't seen each other in a while
due to Dave's busy schedule with work
and his children Mitch reminds Dave of
their plans for the evening which the
latter had completely forgotten
nevertheless he pretends to remember and
degrees to meet up later as soon as they
hang up Mitch receives an unexpected
visit from his father who is
disappointed with his son's lifestyle he
sarcastically says that he's proud of
Mitch for quitting school to become a
commercial model Mitch asks him why he's
there to which his father informs him
that he's remarrying he invites Mitch to
the wedding but Mitch denies later in
the evening Dave is giving his twin
children a bath when his wife jimie
returns home from work she reminds him
about their scheduled dialogue night
appointment but Dave has forgotten this
as well it turns out their counselor
urged them to have a private
conversation once a week but they
haven't done so in 3 months Dave
apologizes and requests Jamie postpone
it one more time a little while later
Mitch picks up Dave and the two friends
head to a bar there they enjoy their
drinks while watching a baseball game
before long their conversation turns to
life matters Dave inquires about Mitch's
dating life and the latter proceeds to
share his experiences with various women
he's been involved with he even shows
Dave a picture of his current intimate
partner Tatiana seeing this Dave
comments on how she reminds him of
beautiful Sabrina he begins to
contemplate whether he made the wrong
choices in life by settling down early
and taking on a 9 to5 job when he could
have had the freedom like Mitch however
Mitch counters this by expressing Envy
for Dave's life pointing out that Dave
is already on his own ground and as a
loving family that prevents him from
feeling lonely let's not forget there's
a third type of guy out there being
single in your 30s and not looking like
Mitch upon exiting the bar in a drunk
State they make their way to a nearby
Fountain to relieve themselves during
this they wish that they had each
other's lives just then the city's
lights go out for a moment the following
morning morning Mitch awakens beside
jimie who's breastfeeding a baby this
startles him and he wakes up with a
bewildered expression upon looking in
the mirror he is shocked to discover
that he now possesses Dave's Body on the
other hand the real Dave is asleep at
Mitch's apartment when he is awakened by
a knock on the door upon answering it he
finds his own body standing in front of
him they both stand in front of a mirror
and completely freak out realizing that
they've switched bodies soon after they
recall the wish they made at the
Fountain the previous night wasting no
time they rush back to the fountain in
an attempt to reverse the switch only to
discover that it has been removed for
restoration they then head to the
district manager's office to find out
the fountain's whereabouts unfortunately
the information is not yet available on
the computer system now Dave is worried
because it's the day for a critical
merger meeting at his firm while Mitch
also has an important movie Shoot to
attend with no immediate solution they
are forced to wait until the Parks
Department locates The Fountain and in
the meantime they must impersonate each
other afterwards Mitch arrives at the
office dressed informally as he walks by
the office kitchen he notices a variety
of food stuffs meant for the staff Mitch
hurridly starts stuffing it all in his
pockets and some into his mouth just
then he's approached by Sabrina to whom
he passes an unprofessional comment
nevertheless she ignores his remark
hands him a merger file and sends him to
the meeting room it takes him a while to
get settled which disrupts the entire
meeting following this one of the
Japanese clients asks Mitch about some
Financial info regarding the company
which completely goes over his head his
lack of professionalism and legal
knowledge sabotages an important merger
enraging Dave's boss meanwhile Dave
inhabiting Mitch's body arrives at a
movie set and soon realizes that it's an
adult film the director volan explains
the scene to him but Dave is reluctant
to perform despite his reservation he
ends up doing the bed scene against his
will after work Mitch attends Dave's
elder sister Cara's ballet class where
he notices her being bullied on their
way home he asks for the reason why she
doesn't fight back in response she
reminds him of Dave's lesson to resolve
fights verbally Mitch disagrees with
this approach and advises her to fight
back for herself from now on later that
night the two best friends meet to
discuss how their respective days went
Mitch admits about the unsuccessful
meeting while Dave expresses how
humiliated he felt during filming
realizing that it won't work like this
anymore they drive to Dave's house to
tell his wife jimie the truth however
she doesn't believe in them and simply
brushes them off Dave urges her to ask
questions that only he would know the
answers to but when she does Dave
responds incorrectly while Mitch
provides the correct answers unable to
convince her Dave resorts to revealing a
personal bathroom incident which only
angers Jamie further as she believes
Dave shared this private story with
Mitch following this Dave drives back to
Mitch's disheveled apartment while Mitch
proceeds for family dinner unaccustomed
to having a proper meal Mitch starts
digging in appearing as if he's been
hungry for days Jaimie and Cara try to
get his attention but they end up
getting disappointed by his crude
remarks and behavior on the other hand
Dave receives a phone call from Tatiana
who tells him that she'll be coming over
to sleep with him anxious about the
situation he calls Mitch who encourages
him to do it since it's what David
always desired shortly after Tatiana
arrives and quickly deres before getting
a top Dave much to his surprise Tatiana
is 9 months pregnant this Revelation
makes Dave hesitant to proceed and
Tatiana leaves in Anger Dave can see the
baby kicking back at Dave's Place Mitch
gets excited when he sees Jaimie
undressing however his enthusiasm soon
Fades as Jaimie proceeds to use the
bathroom right in front of them at
midnight the cries of the twin babies
awakens them and jimie tells Mitch that
it's his turn to feed them Mitch
initially refuses but the enraged jimie
kicks him out of bed not knowing what to
do he carries the babies like sacks to
the kitchen and calls Dave for help
while on the phone the babies begin to
play with dangerous objects like knives
and electrical sockets causing Mitch to
struggle to keep them safe unable to
stand this lifestyle Mitch orders Dave
to locate the fountain at all costs the
next day Dave revisits the district
office and submits a request form to
locate the fountain he gets Furious when
he learns that the approval process
could take up to 3 weeks he then goes to
his place to share the news with Mitch
before that he notices jimie in tears
when asked she confides in him about her
husband's strange Behavior she also
expresses her feelings of a loneliness
and Dave's lack of attention Dave is
saddened by her words but feels
powerless to change the situation later
on he informs Mitch about the lengthy
approval time which infuriates the
latter as well Mitch declares that he
can't endure the life any longer and
contemplates quitting however Dave tells
him not to give up and lectures him on
being a responsible grown-up man after a
while of deliberation Mitch agrees to
play along following this Dave teaches
him everything about himself including
the formal outfits his daily routine
baby handling techniques and so on while
at the office Sabrina informs Mitch
about the resumption of the merger which
relieves Dave just then Mitch introduces
Dave to Sabrina and urges the two of
them to go on a date he goes goes on to
ramble and sets up Dave on a sudden date
with Sabrina because Mitch also has a
crush on her after Dave leaves Mitch
receives a call and he's surprised to
hear his father's voice from the other
end unaware of the swap Mitch's father
calls him for a brief meeting believing
him to be Dave later Mitch now
inhabiting Dave's Body meets with his
own father who tells him about his
second marriage he seeks his help in
convincing his friend who is Mitch
himself to attend the wedding admitting
that he wants his son to be there as as
their conversation unfolds the old man
asserts that his son is a quitter which
deeply upsets Mitch he then takes it as
a motivational factor and vows to become
a better version of Dave from that day
forward Mitch makes a concerted effort
to be a better dad adapt professionalism
at work and strike a better balance
between his professional and personal
lives one evening Mitch attends Cara's
ballet performance with jimie he
foulmouthed Le cheers Cara when she
fights back the bully that night Mitch
seduces jimie to bed he tries to get
aggressive as he's used to doing with
other women but jimie wants to do it
affectionately this causes Mitch's
arousal to cool down making him
frustrated in response Jamie cradles him
and he appreciates the comfort that he's
never felt before in the morning Dave
meets jimie at the grocery store and
asks how she's doing she shares that she
feels better cuz her husband has started
to pay more attention to her as well as
to their children Dave feels relieved to
hear this a few days pass by and we see
that Mitch has now adapted to to Dave's
responsible Lifestyle on the other hand
Dave takes full advantage of being Mitch
he spends his days watching movies
playing baseball smoke in the reef
visiting zoos and more however he's
still not ready when it comes to going
on a date as a result Mitch goes to his
apartment and helps him prepare for the
upcoming date afterwards Dave meets
Sabrina at a classy restaurant he
appears pleased to see her but Sabrina
clarifies that it's not a date and that
she's only there because her boss
instructed her to attend hearing this
Dave suggests that they leave but
Sabrina is hungry so she tells him to
stay during their meal they initiate
some basic conversation and gradually
start opening up to one another as they
go on talking they actually start to
enjoy the evening after dinner Sabrina
suggests doing something adventurous
that they'll regret in the morning and
they both decide to get tattoos
following a wonderful evening Dave walks
Sabrina home and before parting ways she
asks him to call her because she has
changed her mind about it not being a
date in the morning Jamie reminds Mitch
that their anniversary is approaching
and plans to throw a small party when
Mitch brings up his best friend jimie
reminds him that Dave doesn't want Mitch
to join them because he's afraid that
he'll embarrass him this deeply saddens
Mitch but he hides his disappointment
meanwhile Dave is skating in the park
when he receives a call from the
district manager notifying him about the
fountain's location Dave then heads to
the office to share this news with Mitch
while there he meets Sabrina who invites
him to attend a baseball game tomorrow
later Dave informs Mitch about at the
fountain's whereabouts but their relief
seems somewhat half-hearted Mitch
expresses his wish to stay like this for
a while longer because he's really
working hard for the company's merger
deal and wants to prove himself Dave
also agrees and the two postpone the
change up the following day Dave attends
the baseball game with Sabrina while
Mitch goes to the crucial meeting he had
been preparing for during the meeting
the Japanese clients propose a
relatively low offer of
625 million which is fu far from ideal
with limited options Dave's boss and the
company representatives are on the verge
of accepting the offer it is at this
moment when Mitch notices that the other
party's Representatives haven't left yet
this makes him realize that the other
party wants the deal so Mitch insists on
a higher offer of 725 million after this
he makes Dave's firm Representatives
leave scaring the Japanese
Representatives just as they reach the
exit a mediator stops them and agrees to
close the deal at 7:25 leaving everyone
elated Mitch picks the mediator up in
happiness and it's very funny looking in
the evening both Mitch and Dave's
families attend a Gala held by the firm
to honor Dave's achievement he's
becoming partner during the event Jaime
gets emotional by the speech that
Praises Dave's struggle as well as his
family values eventually Mitch comes to
realize that it's Dave who truly
deserves this recognition not him
meanwhile Dave and Sabrina are at a
baseball game when a thunderstorm
suddenly hits drenched in the rain he
takes her to Mitch's Place where things
begin to take a romantic turn as she
undresses herself to get intimate Dave
notices a butterfly tattoo on her body
which reminds him of his daughter at
this point he realizes he must not fool
around like this and leaves the place
abruptly he drives towards the gala and
immediately proceeds to kiss Jamie this
confuses everyone but Jamie realizes the
truth with this the two friends drive
towards the fountain to reverse the SW
upon arriving they hesitate to take
a leak there because the fountain is now
located in the middle of a bustling Mall
surrounded by a crowd of people despite
the awkwardness Dave decides to proceed
with the plan while Mitch still can't
get her done at this moment Mitch brings
up the question of why Dave didn't
invite him to his anniversary party Dave
admits that he was embarrassed but he's
proud of Mitch now this relaxes Mitch
enough to urinate and the two make their
wish for the swap as before the lights
go out and they quickly flee the scene
the following morning Dave and Mitch are
thrilled to find themselves back in
their original bodies Dave wakes up his
wife and expresses How Deeply he values
his family he then gets on to his
fatherly tasks with renewed appreciation
on the other hand Sabrina comes to
Mitch's apartment as she had left her
purse she apologizes for being
aggressive the previous night Mitch
quickly catches up and invites her to
join him for breakfast in the final
scene Mitch attends his father's wedding
and acknowledges his new spouse as his
stepmother the movie ends as Mitch who
is now in a relationship with Sabrina
attends Dave and Jaime's anniversary
celebration subscribe for more videos
like this turn on notifications and
leave a like to help the channel out
thank you for watching